[Music]
what's up guys and welcome to today's
video
in this one i'm going to be showing you
five really useful drills and exercises
that you can do in order to improve your
kicking technique and they're all across
different types of areas so there's a
nice bit of variation in there as well
they're also roughly in order of
importance which is going to be really
useful because there's obviously some
things
that you want to have kind of mastered
or down pat before moving on to more
difficult things
now before we get into the actual tips
what i think a good idea to do is to
begin with watching some footage of
really incredible kickers
now this is going to be different for
everyone's specific taste me personally
i like to watch videos of different
things because i think they've all got
their own values and strengths over each
other
now you really want to look at how these
people are doing it and i don't mean
just watch them and kind of take it in
but i mean really look
watch it frame by frame now even though
it's likely you have an instructor
showing you specific things at your
classes perhaps there's absolutely no
harm
in doing this as well now that might
sound like a bit of a trivial thing to
do you know just watch some footage and
things
but it's a really really effective way
to learn and the more you kind of like
saturate yourself with the things that
you're wanting to accomplish basically
the more likely it is to happen for you
like you might have heard of things like
vision boards and things like that this
is pretty much kind of like a version of
that but in a different way
so that isn't one of the five tips that
i'm going to share however i do think
it's a super important tool
to be utilized like especially if you're
going to be going training or something
like that because that's why i
usually like to do like if i'm gonna if
i'm gonna go training i'll i'll have
kind of like 10 15 minutes maybe
and i'll watch some clips of things that
i'm wanting to practice that day maybe
have a little look at the techniques and
things
i always find that the sessions after
doing that are way better than if i just
kind of i guess rolled out of bed and
went off to the gym or something like
that
[Music]
so here's a list of the things that
we're going to be looking at in the
video this section will be taken by my
buddy andre
victorian who's a performance coach and
the creator of the flex theory method
i've worked with andre quite extensively
over a number of sessions and his
knowledge of combining strength and
flexibility
is absolutely mind-blowing so he's going
to be explaining a little bit of his
training philosophy as well as
demonstrating some exercises as well
so what we're doing first is some slow
kicking drills and i'm holding on to a
chair for balance so that i don't have
to worry about it during the motion
now what i'm doing here is i'm doing a
full extension of a side kick that i
hold out for 10
seconds and then once i've done that i'm
doing 10
slow repetitions you want to try to
really have the best form that you can
on these so that obviously when it
translates to doing it more quickly
that form remains in your muscle memory
so you see here my heel is facing
towards the target
i'm doing a nice chamber extension
re-chamber as i bring it in
and then those are followed by 10 fast
repetitions
and finally finishing on another
extended hold
and as you can see on here i'm
demonstrating with a sidekick but you
can use this for all different types of
kicks as well
now if you try this you will notice
pretty quickly that your glutes
and your obliques start to really ache
as you're holding that kick out and
you'll find probably quite quick
improvements as you do these as their
muscles that probably don't get used
that often
and this one is a bit of a variation
just to change things up a bit i'm doing
one low side kick and one high side kick
and then finally just a mix of different
kicks and this is really good for kind
of getting into those right positions so
really concentrating on where your hips
are placed those chambers and rechambers
and all those important things like that
[Music]
this next one is some traditional line
kicking that you might see in a
taekwondo class perhaps
super basic and controlled but i still
think this is one of the best ways to
get your kicking reps in
so starting nice and low and controlled
and then picking up the height and
intensity as you go now i'm just doing
one kick here but you can mix it up and
do all sorts of different things and at
different intensity levels as well
now the main thing to do is practice
your best form possible in a controlled
way to make everything else second
nature
so it's not so much about practice makes
perfect as the saying goes it's more
like perfect
practice makes perfect
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
next we're going to do some plyometric
jumping drills which are going to be
awesome for developing your explosive
power
now when you're doing these they're
pretty self-explanatory from the footage
but one thing to mention is make sure
that you are jumping from the ground
most people when they do this kind of
exercise stand up first before the jump
and when you do that you're kind of
losing a lot of the benefit so make sure
you really spring explosively from the
ground
and straighten your legs up as you do so
until you come back down and for the
second one as you can see i'm doing like
a lunge type position and you want to
remain in that lunge throughout
basically the same principles apply make
sure you're jumping from the ground
again and extending the legs as you go
also be careful not to smash your knee
into the ground when you come down land
with control and that's also going to
help with your stabilizer muscles too
we're also going to be doing these on
both sides
[Music]
and finally we're doing a switching
version from left to right and vice
versa these are an absolute killer guys
so like i said before be careful how
many you do and i wouldn't recommend
doing them
day after day i'll do them every other
day to start with
[Music]
[Music]
so
so as mentioned earlier for this section
we're going to go over to andre from
flex theory
and his exercises are really good for
helping kick in overall but specifically
between these two points of a kick
and concentrates on strengthening the
hamstring so with that being said let's
go over to andre now
hi i'm coach andre founder of the flex
theory method and today i want to share
one of the really important processes to
the method called the
pull and press now i started doing this
when i was about eight years old
because it felt right i could tell
intuitively without anyone else telling
me that this was working and i saw the
results
it was the beginning of an incredible
athletic career
the way that it works is we pull on
something and we press on something just
how it sounds
the reason it works is because it relies
on
long muscle lengthening and isometric
pushing at the
end of that muscle length that's
important because isometrics
helps you recruit far more muscle fibers
and other methods doing this
at an extreme length helps you produce
hypertrophy and strength in a spot where
you're typically weak
and induces a flexibility response
all right i'm going to demonstrate a
pull and press from a hurdler's position
you don't have to use this position at
all
this isn't about the position it's about
the process which is the pull and press
you can do that from
say a straddle if you wanted to and it
can be a short straddle need not be wide
at all to get to your hamstrings
now what i'm going to do here is i'm
going to grab around my foot because i
can
if you cannot grab somewhere else on
your leg underneath because you're going
to need a good grip
what's better than that good grip
outside of your foot
is using a towel around the foot or a
band or a cloth or something that you
have
choking up on it going as far as you can
and then doing the next step
which would be to drop the elbows once
the elbows are down you don't have to
make it to the floor
you have to seek the floor and let your
body respond to intention
from that point you are going to use
your biceps your
shoulders your back and pull yourself
forward elongating your spine so that
you
bend at the pelvic bone inducing
additional stress outside of just the
position
by the pool you will feel it right away
it will feel much different
and once you're in that position and
you're pulling as hard as you will allow
yourself to
you press down into the floor while you
keep pulling
and you will count here for somewhere
between
10 and 30. start with 10 build up to
a higher number over time and then
you're going to release keep your body
down straighten out the arms
press that heel into the floor and you
will gently and gracefully
come back up and that's how you'll come
up from everything and that's the pull
and press
it will build the hamstrings incredibly
well
it will also give you a flexibility
response that's unlike
anything else i have ever seen i will
show you
just very quickly i've done this without
any weights whatsoever
that is from doing the pull and press
and
five or six other components of the flex
theory method
with those processes placed into
positions i hope this helps
these torso raises happen from a side
kick position resting on a wall and help
to strengthen the oblique muscles in a
way that helps you recover balance from
high kicking more quickly
and helps with overall kick stability so
rest your leg on the wall but not too
high to start with
bend at the waist all the way down
holding guard raise back up and focusing
upon using the obliques predominantly
with that mind muscle connection
and when you're at the top you want to
pinch the oblique slightly for a split
second before repeating the movement
[Music]
[Music]
once you've done these you're going to
hold the top position and perform 10
small crunches of the obliques before
completion
[Music]
something really important to mention
here about the alignment of this
you see on this clip i'm not in
alignment and i'm kind of coming out to
the side as i race towards the top
if you do this you're not going to be
hitting the muscles correctly so make
sure that you stay in line almost as if
you're kind of
between two panes of glass and moving
between
[Music]
so that concludes this video today guys
i wanted to make this one a little bit
more simple from my usual
kind of like informational based videos
so if you like this kind of style of
video let me know
and i will be able to produce more of
them in the future and lastly head over
to my youtube channel i've got a spin
hook kick tutorial scheduled to go live
the same time as this video
and it's youtube.com grantstevensma